within the 70 billion U.S wedding
industry the knot has established itself
as one of the most popular online
destinations for brides and grooms
founded in 1996 the knot became a unique
place to find wedding inspiration
vendors and create websites and gift
registries
so when you think of the knot you think
of weddings and you know love and
celebration and happiness and smiling
couples but
the fascinating thing about this story
is hearing the stories inside the
company
stories of intimidation and deceit which
is really the antithesis of that
at the core of the Knot's alleged dark
side are testimonies from former
longtime employees who accuse the
company of defrauding investors and
advertisers
we first heard about some potential
issues at the knot from a group of
whistleblowers who reached out via an
organization that they were working with
called lioness which is a platform that
helps whistleblowers and insiders that
companies come forward to expose
potential wrongdoing what we did was we
used the claims that the whistleblowers
had come forward with as only the
jumping off point for a much larger and
deeper investigation into some of the
issues that they raised
the group of whistleblowers that came
forward alleged that the knot had been
committing financial fraud for years
accelerating Revenue which means that
they were claiming revenue for services
that they had not yet or would never
deliver and The Whistleblower is also
alleged that the executives of the
company at the time that they were there
had orchestrated what they called a
quote textbook pump and dump to
essentially drive up the company stock
price before it was sold to a pair of
private Equity firms for almost a
billion dollars in 2018. we had multiple
sources who were alleging that
advertisers both big and small were
getting swindled
and that workers were intimidated to
cover it up for example we heard from
somebody who talked about higher-ups and
execs standing behind their shoulder and
you know wanting them to go into
internal systems and and change the
contract terms because the company
wasn't delivering we heard from vendors
who were complaining about not getting
out of their contract and being stuck in
in Auto renewal
and we heard from folks who were buying
ad units that at some sometimes didn't
exist
Jennifer Davidson was one of the
whistleblowers who worked at the knot
for over two decades most recently as a
global fashion director
she told Forbes even major Partners such
as Macy's and David's Bridal were
spending millions of dollars a year on
ad spaces that did not always exist
Davidson says several of the contracts
she'd overseen personally including with
big name fashion houses like Allure and
Justin Alexander had been changed
discreetly without telling the clients
and Tech glitches were so frequent that
ads would often inexplicably disappear
from the site or never run at all
the knot has denied any wrongdoing they
have emphasized repeatedly that the
claims that the whistleblowers came
forward with in 2017 have been
thoroughly investigated and that they
were thoroughly investigated
investigated by both an outside Council
and also internally they've also
emphasized that the government did
investigate them and the pro that probe
was was uh was closed and then the
company also I think has been trying to
distance itself from what has happened
with past leadership so there's sort of
the world of the knot before it was sold
in 2018 and the world of the not after
it was sold in 2018. since we published
our story we've heard from
uh vendors from clients who corroborated
some of this this reporting and uh still
have complaints today so it's
um
the suggestion that that some of these
these issues are still ongoing it's hard
to say what lines were crossed legally
but we did talk to experts in in
business and management who said that
they did feel that they were Shady
business practices going on
allegations of questionable business
practices at the knot also extend to
small vendors in the wedding industry
such as DJs and photographers
many of the small businesses in
particular that we spoke to described
very low Roi and these are small
businesses that you know don't have
large budgets that were shelling out uh
thousands in some cases tens of
thousands of dollars to advertise on the
knot who said that they received little
to no Roi and that in fact they received
a lot of spam or scam leads a lot of the
complaints from smaller vendors like
like DJs and and venue owners were that
the leads that they were getting were
pretty useless
um that it was a lot of spam the service
just wasn't helpful and they were also
complaining about being able to get out
of their contracts and being misled
about contract terms and just kind of
being stuck in this Auto renewal uh that
that they just couldn't escape
the company has responded to that saying
that not all services make every
be
and there are always going to be issues
with some people not sort of getting out
of any kind of service or any kind of
tech company what they believe they
signed up for but they have sort of you
know dismissed that as one-off cases and
not as widespread issues
these allegations of shady business
practices and fraudulent transactions
come at a time when the knot may be
considering going public once again
it previously went public on the NASDAQ
just before the turn of the Millennium
and had scooped up competitors such as
weddingchannel.com the company expanded
to offer services for other major life
Milestones including the bump for
helping couples starting a family and
the nest for building a home
these Brands and several others were
brought under an umbrella company called
EXO group before selling to private
Equity firms and merging with rival
company wedding wire in 2018.
the company IPO is purely speculative at
this point we have heard from both
insiders and Outsiders that they believe
that that is sort of where the company
is headed at this point in time but part
of the reason that these allegations are
really problematic is because they come
against the backdrop of a really
intensely competitive environment
already where the knot is struggling to
keep up with competitors like Zola and
also and probably even even you know
on an even larger scale struggling with
the popularity of social media we spoke
to an industry analyst who said that
these these websites are actually kind
of falling out of fashion the biggest uh
driver of this kind of thing is is
Google searches and then it's Word of
Mouth
um and then it's these kinds of websites
and then it's social media and so
um I think the knot is kind of trying to
figure out its place in this more
you know robust ecosystem
the irony was not lost on us or many of
the employees that we spoke to that this
is at the end of the day a wedding
company focused on one of the most
special and uh memorable moments of a
person's life and yet here's this
company that on the inside according to
employees is very Cutthroat is in many
cases a toxic work environment is a
company that is pressuring employees to
cross ethical lines according to the
employees themselves as one employee so
aptly put it this is a wedding company
it's not like chemical weapons and I
think that that perfectly sums up the
the irony of the fact that this is a
company with a very festive facade that
appears to have many troubles Brewing on
the inside